the us government's fight to break up
facebook continues the federal trade
commission renewed its lawsuit against
the social media giant with fresh
arguments for its anti-trust complaint
the crux of it remains the same the ftc
accuses facebook of illegally crushing
competition by buying up rivals like
instagram and whatsapp or burying them
with strong arm tactics the new filing
is substantially longer than the
original according to the new york times
it also has more facts and analysis to
back up its argument
a federal judge dismissed the ftc's
initial suit back in june the judge said
that the government failed to prove that
facebook has an illegal monopoly but the
agency got a second chance to make its
case
in response facebook says the ftc still
has no valid claims it accused the
agency of trying to rewrite antitrust
laws and promise to vigorously defend
itself and yes that is facebook
defending itself in tweets very meta the
suit comes as facebook ceo mark
zuckerberg continues to face questions
about misinformation on the platform he
spoke to cbs's gail king this week about
coveted misinformation
if we see harmful misinformation on the
platform and we take it down it's
against our policies so the 18 million
number that i shared is the number of
pieces of content that um that we've
seen on the platform that
that we take down you've taken down 18
million pieces of misinformation but how
many people have viewed the
misinformation is it more than 18
million
is it less than 18 million that's the
number i think people are talking about
i understand what you're saying i mean
the number that i have off the top my
head that i can share is the number of
pieces of misinformation that we've
taken action against
so far mr zuckerberg has yet to answer
that question we also reached out to
facebook and asked them about the reach
of those 18 million removed posts
company has yet to respond
meanwhile twitter is testing out another
way to combat misinformation for the
first time the platform will let users
report tweets that they believe are
misleading members will be able to
choose whether the flag tweet pertains
to politics health or other
misinformation the test feature is
currently only available in the us
australia and south korea
twitter notes that this is a small
experiment for now and it may not act on
every flagged tweet
joining us now is kara swisher new york
times contributing opinion writer and
host of the podcast sway it is so good
to see you again and i wonder first of
all what your thoughts are on this ftc
suit whether this one seems more likely
to stick and if it does what's at stake
for facebook it seems like the ftc's
efforts to kind of prod and poke and
regulate facebook over the years
have
not really
drawn a lot of blood they seem to have
made a lot of headlines but i don't know
if they've really had a huge impact
well they haven't done much i mean they
did a fine many many years ago and then
they re-upped it with a consent decree
but not they haven't really done
anything they've actually kind of passed
and given them a parking ticket for the
most part this is their most aggressive
effort so far and i think it's going to
be difficult for them because of judges
and there needs to be a rewrite of
anti-trust laws to be able to deal with
companies like facebook and amazon and
many others that don't fit into the
traditional way antitrust is viewed
today by judges and i think that's going
to be their biggest challenge is not
necessarily people thinking it's a good
idea or other things but either congress
has to act and change anti-trust laws
and rewrite them which it's working on
in some ways or judges have to be
amenable to their arguments which is
very difficult it's a it's a pretty high
bar that the fdc is going to have to
climb now that it has aggressive people
in place willing to do these kind of
things
where do you see the efforts to try to
rethink the regulations around
monopolies to adapt to social media
companies i mean it's hard to forget
that exchange before a senate committee
where i think it was orrin hatch of utah
who asked mark zuckerberg how his
company makes money and he's like
senator we run ads like where is
congress on this right now oh you know
he's just he's an outlier many of the
people working on this are quite
intelligent about the internet sending
it senator klobuchar there's a number on
the republican side ken bucks many
others um who are working on it in a
bipartisan way now everyone has their
different reasons um for what why they
want to do it conservatives think
there's bias et cetera et cetera but
it's it's more about power and so i
think there's a very there's a
bipartisan feeling that something has to
be done whether it's the reform of
section 230 or a rewrite of anti-trust
laws to reflect a very different kind of
corporate uh hegemony that is not in the
traditional sense now again i'm not a
lawyer but i i talk to a lot of lawyers
and from what i understand it's a really
difficult um
mountain the ftc has to climb given the
sherman antitrust act is so old and
doesn't reflect the new digital times
and especially with companies that are
so popular that don't necessarily raise
prices are in fact free for the most
part and so that's the difficult part
and and the other part is that they can
do whatever they want and that's the i
think the problem that we have as you
just saw in that interview with mark
zuckerberg and gail
with regards to misinformation there was
another exchange from that interview
where he tried to put a little nuance on
what we broadly referred to as
misinformation here's another part of
what he said watch
where a lot of the the stuff that's
actually the hardest for us to um
to to really
address
is not what i would call misinformation
but instead another category that i
would call hesitancy when you were first
thinking about getting your vaccine you
probably had questions around you know
which vaccine is the most effective for
you and your family and in some of these
times when people ask these questions or
or is this safe yet should i wait a
while um that's not misinformation
uh but it's it's certainly
um
you know contributing to an environment
where people are asking questions about
the safety of vaccines i don't think we
should ban it
carol what do you make of that
it's just nonsense it's ridiculous i
mean i'm sorry there is there is real
misinformation about stuff that's on
that platform and he's trying to mix it
with normal discussions people have
about their health on lots of issues
should i take this flu medicine or that
flu medicine or whatever and so the two
don't meet and they know the difference
and i think there is some very virulent
serious misinformation by bad players
that are trying to create an a very
anti-vaccine thing versus people just
questioning and no one's telling people
they can't question and so to put the
two up against each other is nonsense as
far as i can tell the other part is that
18 million thing you were talking about
again
i don't know what that means it's a
number without anything else next to it
18 million what how many times where who
from whom they they never like to give
actual specifics and they've done that
time and again um for for it it's long
history they give numbers that have no
meaning or that you can't glean any
meaning from and so uh and they and they
prefer not to answer them and say things
like off the top of my head you know he
has a he has a paper that has all that
information right on it he's nothing's
off the top of his head um so it's it's
kind of comical to watch that happen
before i move on to one other story what
do you make of the efforts to try to
stamp out misinformation or at least
deal with it differently including this
uh test feature that twitter has
it's interesting i don't particularly
want to paint twitter's fence for it
right i mean that's the thing when these
when these things come in you know lots
of police departments have this kind of
thing and they check out tips and things
like that but this is a massive amount
if people keep checking it off do you
everything all the really bad stuff is
going to get buried under the what
you're just talking about which is
someone's opinion you know i don't like
masks well that's you can't someone
might report that and that's not you
shouldn't take that down in any way
people could not like mask that's fine
or i don't i don't think mass work that
should be allowed to be said obviously
and so i think it makes it really
difficult it's you know it's just you
can't do this in an analog piecemeal way
there has to be a much bigger way to do
it but the fact that matters the
architecture of this stuff makes it
almost impossible to fix in the in the
way it's built
from what i can understand from
technology
another story i want to ask you about
before i have to let you go that's
gotten a lot of buzz this week is a big
change that's coming to this
subscription user generated content site
called only fans there is a tremendous
amount of adult content on only fans not
all but a lot and the company says that
as of this october it will begin banning
quite a bit of the sexually explicit
content especially sexually explicit
photos and videos but to comply with
requests from its banking partners and
payout providers only fans has been
highly controversial but it's also
fairly well known that some people
during the pandemic turn to only fans to
make extra income during the pandemic
some have made quite a bit of money so
it's been a lifeline for some
i wonder what you make of this
especially because this feels just like
what tumblr did when they were like no
no we're going clean now we're rising up
in the world and then
that didn't really pan out for them so
what's going on here
well it depends on how you feel about
sex work right and how you feel about
how it should be paid especially if it's
consenting adults and then it also this
is what this company has been doing
which is allowing this to happen um i
think the issue is just like with credit
card companies i interviewed they had a
mastercard this was an issue with them
is whether they you know a lot want to
be in a payment system on these on these
platforms and i think that's the
difficulty there's a lot of pushback
from different groups and then they
can't get the payment systems they need
that there's so much of the back end of
the internet that people don't pay
attention to but it's very important to
only fans the other thing is if they're
trying to attract um funding i suspect
that a lot of people are sort of don't
want to invest in that or the people
they want to invest in that or if they
go public and stuff like that it's much
more difficult because how we look at
look at what's happening on this site
and some of it is probably problematic
other stuff probably should be allowed
but it makes it really difficult for
them to
deal with financial issues and also to
raise money
and briefly before i have to let you go
the wall street journal is reporting
that amazon is interested in opening
brick and mortar retail locations kind
of like department stores possibly in
ohio and california i still love the
fact that amazon has bookstores when it
started killing bookstores by being
amazon cara what is this about before i
let you go
well it's the board continuing to grow i
mean they like retail and it gives them
lots more data and it's you know it's a
real opportunity right now with a
pandemic a lot of department stores have
gone belly up or they're having real
problems or contracting and they have
there's lots of opportunity for amazon
here secondly they don't have they've
been trying to get into fashion and
clothing a lot and a lot of brands don't
want to be on the amazon site next to
their batteries and so if they want to
attract others other brands and sell
more because that's a big part of their
business they have to do this and so i
think this is completely within their
what they've been doing is slowly
marching out into every aspect of
commerce